[Musique]
aussi les images de vidéosurveillance de
l'agression raciste d'un livreur venu
récupérer une commande dimanche soir à
cergy
ce dernier est interpellé violemment par
un homme qui le pousse avant de se
diriger vers lui pour le rouer de coups
après juste votre votre intérêt quand je
suis tombé par terre parce que lui est
venue sous - commence à me tabasser par
ce que j'ai dit au secours dans ce qu il
y a le pire de l'immigration avec cet
individu raciste et puis il ya aussi le
meilleur avec cette dame qui sort son
portable courageusement pour dénoncer ce
racisme et pour promouvoir l'ordre
public sur le territoire mais elle subit
à son tour des menaces et insultes
racistes et traiter d'esclaves par
l'agresseur et puisque seuls moi je
pense qu'il faut véritablement passé un
tour de vis il faut rétablir l'autorité
de l'état
des propos condamnables devant un
tribunal protégé par la police le patron
de l'établissement est pris à partie
mais il nie être l'employeur de
l'agresseur désigné nous adaptons
l'ensemble de notre chaîne pénale au
nombre de places de prison
mais nous partons au drame au chaos et
emmanuel macron n'a strictement rien
fait pour régler ce problème l'agresseur
présumé a été interpellé à la mi journée
à paris
mourad des bientôt 24 ans est connu de
la justice pour une vingtaine de faits
rue saint vincent de paul dans l'après
midi en plein passage sur le trottoir un
homme qui se drogue
des images qui se répète face à cette
salle de shoot est sous les yeux des
habitants du quartier on sentait que les
digues étaient en train de lâcher et ils
ont refusé à ce moment-là d'apporter
cette clarification
il la mène aujourd'hui mais les digues
ont lâché vous venez de le rappeler donc
un certain nombre ont déjà franchi le
pas en direction du parti de madame le
pen
les crises révèle ceux qui tiennent le
cap dans la tempête et ceux qui se
laissent aller
ceux qui se laissent aller
ceux qui confondent la fermeté et la
démagogie
ceux qui confondent l'efficacité et
l'outrance
est-ce que vous fracturé un cadenas
risque pas de bus ni l'arrêt nord du
parti aujourd'hui ce qui signerait
l'arrêt de mort du parti si on n'est pas
capable de se mettre d'accord pour
désigner un candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
ça sera notre arrêt de mort parce qu'on
sera mis dans la seringue entre mâcon et
le pen vous pouvez comme d'autres avoir
envie de présider la rochelle
perspective ne me fait pas peur je me
prépare et je serai au rendez-vous
préparé je me prépare la réalité c'est
que la question que vous posez une
question très grave il ya clavier
bertrand hier valérie pécresse il ya un
certain nombre de leaders
mecheri dans les échos il a été votre
ministre des affaires étrangères j'ai
envie aujourd'hui d'être utiles pour que
chaque français ce qu'ils étaient chaque
français qui est nécessaire qui est
utile qui a une valeur ajoutée se disent
qu'il peut être fier de participer au
succès de la france eric piolle est en
garde à vue le maire écologiste de
grenoble est entendu depuis ce matin
dans une affaire d'attribution de
marchés publics très la fête des tuiles
en 2017 la procédure remonte à plusieurs
années
j'apporte toujours mon soutien aux
écologistes surtout que là ça m'a l'air
d'être une affaire picrocholines mais
voilà la justice fait son travail fait
au service de
la justice évidemment en tant que patron
de l'administration municipale
c'est bien normal et donc j'ai répondu à
leurs questions je justiciables comme
monsieur et madame tout le monde
c'est une annonce solennelle à la
télévision chinoise
un message officiel pour autoriser les
couples à avoir trois enfants chez
sogeti une décision pour améliorer la
politique des naissances et promouvoir
le développement équilibré à long terme
de la population a été prise